well no doubt sunday's soccer game is
going to be packed
thousands expected to attend the u.s
versus mexico game but if you've been to
the stadium
you know parking can be really bad
remember this
this video was taken after the garth
brooks concert this show is just a mass
of people
walking back to their cars and
temperatures that exceeded 100 degrees
the backup was crazy
so many complaints so tonight we're
going to focus on game day
christian casadas joining us now in
studio with some different options on
how to get to
and from the game and how much it could
cost you kristen well denise we all
remember those large crowds that you
were talking about after the garth
brooks concert earlier this month at
allegiant stadium
many claiming it was a nightmare so the
solution according to allegiant stadium
plan ahead the very first step we
recommend is to go to the allegiant
stadium website once you're on there
go to the plan your visit tab which is
up on the top there
you will see this tab right here it's
the gold cup parking map
that will go specifically to the event
that we're talking about
once you click on that you will be
directed to this map you see the stadium
up here
overall you can see that there's 19
parking lots
that you have an option to select
including the garage over here which is
on reno and
valley view boulevard so as you can see
a lot of those are just away from the
stadium so make sure that you wear
comfortable shoes because you're going
to have to be walking a lot now
this is where it gets tricky so if you
have all these options here you also
have an option
for the right share if you decide to do
an uber or a lift you have an area up
here
up by the north part of the stadium also
for taxis you have that area
just west of the stadium but like i said
there's a lot of options for you but
you do have to walk a lot so make sure
again that you are wearing those
comfortable shoes another option that we
have
are the rtc bus they run 24 7 every 15
minutes
with the closest stop near the sienna
bridge at the mandalay bay that's the
pedestrian walkway
from las vegas boulevard which closes to
automobile traffic
during events but the biggest question
here is how much
will this cost you well right there on
your screen we have a list for you
starting off with a 24 hour bus pass
that will cost you
eight dollars rideshare apps obviously
can vary on price depending on your
location
stadium parking will set you back a
hundred bucks but there are some options
nearby that will cost
less that information is on the website
and remember allegion stadium
is a cashless stadium so debit or credit
cards
or mobile payments are allowed but again
the biggest and most important piece of
information here is to plan ahead know
how you're going to get to and from the
stadium because obviously
you don't want to get caught denise and
brian later on in those social media
videos walking
miles and miles before you get home
again all that information available
right now on our website
eightnewsnow.com
christian casadas 8 news now